Let's first rewrite the factors within this term, so that the factors of the
same bases are next to each other. And I'm also going to put the constant factor
first. So I'm going to start with 3 squared, then we have 2 factors that have a
base of x. So I'll put those next to each other, and then the last thing we have
is the y cubed. Well, we know that 3 squared is just 3 times 3, and 3 times 3 is
just 9. We also know that when we have x to the 5th times x to the 8th, that's
the same as x to the 5 plus 8 power, and nothing is being involved with the y
cubed, so it's just going to stay the same. You'll notice I got bit of those
multiplication signs between the different factors in the term. Since they are
implied, we just don't write them. Now, the thing you need to simplify here is
add together the two numbers in the exponent of the x. So you get the final
answer of 9x to the 13, y to the 3rd. I think that you're going to find all of
this practice with manipulating exponents really useful, as we keep simplifying
expressions.